bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors on vient
d'écouter les propos de la ministre lise
trucks en avez-vous pensé
bonjour elle reprend effectivement le
discours qui est très à la mode ces
derniers temps à savoir que ça y est la
russie parce qu'elle a des trous
militaire en russie sur son territoire
se prépare à agresser l'ukraine c'est un
discours qui permet en fait d'essayer de
resserrer les liens entre
les etats-unis et les pays cette énigme
qui sont l'union européenne mais
également de là parce que il faut bien
se regrouper autour d'anne et contraint
à l'ennemi commun et s'éteignit étant
présenté comme étant la russie là aussi
de son côté répète plusieurs fois
qu'elle n'a pas du tout l'intention
d'agresser l'ukraine mais que en
revanche elle ne laissera pas passer une
intervention militaire une force
militaire contre le dopage alors cette
rencontre des ministres du g7 la
rencontre seul avec emmanuel macron la
rencontre seul avec un char nichelle
avec à chaque fois le dossier ukrainien
qui revient sur la table pourquoi ce
dossier l'air de concentrer toutes les
attentions
parce qu'il est très pratique
il les a il laissa alors le dispute
poser est absolument primaire donc il
peut être répétée à souhait et jusqu'à
écoeurement donc on continue comme ça
par un discours extrêmement simplifié à
stigmatiser un pays et de la même
manière à cacher ce qui se passe dans
l'autre pays en europe en ukraine 1
puisque toutes les dérives nationalistes
à toutes les attaques de l'armée
ukrainienne contre les populations du
dombass qui se renforce ces derniers
temps ne sont pas du tout incorporé dans
le dispositif dental le renforcement de
l'aide apportée par les états unis par
les pays de l'otan le renforcement des
programmes
on va dire de formation des militaires
ukrainien on n'en parle pas dans le
discours occidental car on ne parle pas
non plus dans des jeux pro occidental de
renforcement de l'activité en verre noir
ces derniers jours par exemple avec la
chute ils craignent haine qui a fait des
tentatives
avec un avion espion américain qui a été
accompagné par les forces militaires us
pour les écarter un peu de la frontière
russe donc c'est un discours aux
vêtements asymétrique c'est ce que l'on
appelle simple pion de la propagande
pour cent dans le cadre d'une propagande
me dis ouvertement contrat pays en
l'occurrence la russie qui doit incarner
le mal absolu
les intérêts derrière sont très simples
aussi au-delà de cette question
géopolitique générale comme l'a souligné
la ministre britannique se pose la
question aussi du gaz et
le fait de devoir contraindre les pays
européens à simon renoncer en tout cas
diminuer leur part de gaz russe qui est
moins cher nicky et russe en est donc
forcément derrière de retransférer le
marché dans les états unis alors
l'attitude de dubaï donnant précisément
avec la russie joe biden qui s'est
entretenu il ya quelques jours avec
vladimir poutine justement cette vision
conférence a servi à quoi
rien
absolument à rien puisque de toute
manière chacun a
insisté sur sa position et à répéter le
discours heureusement la russie n'a pas
fait de compromis ce qui au moins a été
important qu'elle ne cède pas ça peut
être été le seul intérêt mais sinon
aucun puisque de toute façon by donne
n'était pas dans une disposition les
états unis ne sont pas dans une
disposition peu dispo
ils sont dans une disque dans une
exposition d'imposition et veulent
imposer leur vision du monde une vision
du monde chez eux ça ne se négocie pas
la russie elle n'a pas accepté a
rapetissé minutes inite qui n'ont pas
été acceptées reconnu par les états unis
parce que les états unis sont en
position actuellement de force de ce
côté là et ils n'ont aucune raison a
priori pour accepter les lignes rouges
de la russie si elle même ne les impose
pas par une vision stratégique beaucoup
plus fort alors différent
alors on a cette potentielle d'adhésion
de l'ukraine à l'otan moscow times
qu'une telle admission on pourrait
générer des menaces aux portes de la
russie à quel point
le problème de l'ukraine et que c'est un
territoire ce n'est plus d'un état parce
que c'est un territoire qui est
concrètement dirigé de l'extérieur donc
qui agit non pas dans son intérêt
national année qui est instrumentalisée
pour défendre des intérêts qui vont même
à l'encontre de son propre intérêt
national
donc si l'ukraine en train dans l'otan
il y a une possibilité de mettre en
place non plus que maintenant des
programmes de formation un de l'armée
ukrainienne à part les pays potence et
des bases de l'otan aux portes de la
russie avec un territoire a
confié actifs dont basse
autrement dit il peut y avoir des
risques un de provocation pour que les
tirs de l'armée ukrainienne dépasse la
limite de dons basse et touche les
territoires russe a
hélas la question qui va se poser à voir
et comment la russie dans ce cas l'avs a
réagi à est ce que cela est réellement
de l'intérêt de l'europe non et la
question se pose ici aussi savoir et
quel intérêt dans ce cas-là défendeurs
européens qui soutiennent à ce point la
position des états unis
car élevé chez agone au fco merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur invité
l'université d'état de moscou merci à
vous